ukulele über lange zeit gar nicht mehr
auf mein kanal vorhanden viele leute
haben sie vermisst und viele haben sich
auch gefragt wo die überhaupt waren all
das was du kuli in der zwischenzeit
gemacht hat wo wir nicht bei mir war
dede jetzt im folgenden clip
eingeblendet
[Musik]
einbringen
sie alle machen und über können also
wenn du das gegeben die kleinste vip
card im urlaub hat klopp wäre ich weiß
nicht ob kollege ihre video eben gehen
aber ich liebe grüße aus dem versteck
überbreiten und ich hoffe dass kollege
bei mir viel prämien jetzt kommt mir der
call ist heute nur sagen dafür
vielleicht mache wirklich mal treffen
sollten
gegen neun oder so eine mittagspause
bauch vorbei bis später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo bleibt er denn
doch schon 9 uhr
die polizei was ist den besitzer zum
buch spielt noch passen müssen
ich habe heute mittag ein video gewesen
von luca aber durchaus öfter seine
videos oder gegen das pferd von mir
geredet und wenn ich wieder zurückkomme
möchtest du deinem körper
ich weiß mich es ist okay wenn du wieder
zurück möglich wenn du mir verspricht
und ab und zu besuchen zu kommen
die falschen um die es doch bei der
bundeswehr
was ist denn für einer
[Musik]
na ja und nun ich werde dabei geben
bekomme ich ein wenig über eine umarmung
und klar kommt er
ich werde dich vermissen ich mich auch
juli
hast du mit intendant meinhard pargger
vk
das hier war jetzt noch mal quasi die
story hinter der story wo überhaupt wahr
wir vielleicht früher an übelster
bestandteile mein video und dann haben
wir halt angeboten machen kann als
übrigens in der beschreibung verlinkt
das ist ein kollege von mir die
bekannten videos gemacht hat mit den
kollegen blogs und angeboten hey schicke
nochmal politiker aus haßloch wäre und
danach ökologie natürlich direkt gesagt
ja
ist dabei und dann hat man halt mehrere
block mit ukulele gedreht die wurden ja
auch alle auf meinem kanal hochgeladen
und dann habe ich aber in letzter zeit
marke bei paypal idee mal wieder hier
mit dem namen wieder irgendwelche videos
aufnehmen durch die einfache mit am
start ist dann hat man mir gesagt ja
noch ein abschließendes video drehen die
ukulele quasi mein outfit wird wieder
zurückkommen soll und dann war ich quasi
auf mich und das war das was ihr quasi
gerade gesehen habt wenn euch das ganze
video hier gefallen hat würden wir und
liefert einen like von euch freuen ihr
pils kanal und in der beschreibung
verlinkt der macht auf einem kanal bei
so was wieder den alten ruinen reingeht
und aufwerten machen juni wollten auf
jeden fall mal ab 9 findet ihr hier oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnt ihr einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren verfahren keine videos mehr
da oben findet ihr auch bei den shop
eingeblendet wo heute neue hobbys
gelaunt sind und hier unten ist ein
weiteres video verlinkt und sorry das
ist auch nicht lumpen stift aber das war
eine bestrafung von einer anderen
aufnahme gerade